good morning Hank it's Tuesday I
finished filming crash course US history
early yesterday so I drove down to the
Indianapolis Museum of Art where Sarah
is a curator by the way we have our own
spring snow in Indianapolis walked into
the museum and then into the entry lobby
currently home to this installation by
the great Spencer Finch called following
nature which there curated and which
abstractly recreates Monet's famous
garden at Giverny upstairs I went to
visit I Weiwei according to what I think
I Weiwei is probably the most important
artist alive and my wife not to brag is
responsible for this shows only tour
stopped in the Midwest the show follows
eyes entire career he lived in New York
from 1981 to 1993 hanging out with the
likes of Allen Ginsberg working as a
photojournalist taking many pictures of
himself and then he returned to China
and worked in the artist community
Beijing East Village which included many
Chinese performance artists who would
later become like wildly famous but
you've probably never heard of the Menk
because this isn't really your scene and
it's kind of like trying to explain to
someone how super famous and amazing
Daily Grace is and they're just like oh
you mean the girl from the Lowe's
commercials anyway AI weiwei went on to
his Lowe's commercial consulting on the
bird's nest from the Beijing Olympics
which you probably do remember although
he later distanced himself from it
calling the entire affair of pretend to
smile which if you remember the Beijing
opening ceremony yeah he has continued
to take pictures of himself including
this one when he was detained by the
police and beaten so badly that he
suffered a subdural hematoma he uploaded
that selfie to Twitter by the way I is
primarily famous on tumblr for flicking
off important buildings but his work is
very broad and as is often the case with
contemporary art it can be difficult to
see what's so interesting without
context like these sculptures each made
of more than 2,000 pounds of pressed tea
leaves call to mind the minimalist
sculptures of the likes of Donald Judd
and Carl Andre but I uses distinctly
Chinese material material that has long
been imported by the West what is being
appropriated and by whom in these
cultural and economic exchanges or look
at this neolithic baz painted with the
coke logo or this triptych of i dropping
a han dynasty urn
how do we respond when confronted with
the reality that the destruction of the
old' is inherent to creating anything
new these are interesting and important
questions both for art historians and
for regular people but by far my
favorite work in the AI weiwei show is
this 38 tons of steel rebar array
in undulating waves after the 2008
Sichuan earthquake I went there and
photographed the rescue efforts to
destroyed buildings the awful clusters
of backpacks belonging to dead children
many blame shoddy construction by
corrupt government contractors for the
collapse of so many schools more than
5,000 children died and I spearheaded
the project to record their names as you
stand in the gallery you hear those
names read around this is one of the
saddest wall labels I've ever seen
running time three hours
forty ten minutes all this steel is from
destroyed schools it was bent and
buckled by the earthquake and then I and
his assistants hammered all of it all 38
tons of it straight again poetry makes
nothing happen WH Auden once famously
wrote it is a way of happening a mouth
straightening this rebar didn't bring
back those children or hold the shoddy
contractors accountable it made nothing
happen but the way of happening
threatens the Chinese government enough
that they detain and threaten Iowa Way
because in a world supersaturated with
tragic statistics where even photographs
and videos can lose their punch I found
a way to bring form to love and anger
and grief that's why good art matters so
much Hank and why it is always mattered
even if it does make nothing happen I'll
see you on Friday
[Music]